so how do you choose which story to tell
yeah and how do you choose how to tell
that story yeah
well in terms of how to how to choose
which story
um
you know it's it's a bit of a mystery
potion for me frankly um
i i go often on instinct but there's
also a highly intentional piece of it
for me as well and the intentional piece
is
i guess i'd call it the do i care
threshold you know or the so what
threshold you personally just
something in your heart just kind of
gets ex excited or hurts or just feels
something so one of the things that
disturbs the amount of american culture
lex is is that you know we seem to be a
people that's fascinated by reality
television for example like like look at
how many of us here in america
watch reality television right that
deeply disturbs me not that i've never
watched an episode i've shot a whole
season of it once to make a living right
so it's like i i know it right
but
i feel like the things we should be
paying attention to
are the things personally are the things
i choose to film
right
as a human being
as a dad
as a filmmaker
i think we should be paying attention
to the fact that children are being
starved in yemen i think we should be
paying attention to the fact that
ukrainians are being displaced by the
millions so there's this so what
threshold that i use and i feel like it
has to be a topic
that if we don't cover and we don't put
out in the world
in the largest possible way in the hope
of intervening in the hope of marshaling
maximum resources and attention to
solving the problem
that's what i'm dedicated to as a
filmmaker
because i didn't pick up a camera
initially
to
film puppy dogs right to make people
smile
i believe the camera is a tool for
change i believe the camera
is a powerful tool that we can use
to raise awareness and martial resources
and help people understand
the impact that these geopolitical
decisions have on real people's lives
and that's the that that's the intent
i create each film with
now how i choose each story that's the
the magic potion piece of it right and
and um often one flows rather
organically into another frankly
so you just kind of like you said you go
with instinct a little bit to some
extent but oftentimes i choose the next
project based on relationships i've
developed yeah in the last film
right um and so one often flows into
another through relationships i develop
and then a colleague will share a detail
about something that's happening in a
certain place
and i'll go hmm
really i didn't know that right and it
usually it's before it's hit the world
stage in a big way and so i start to do
due diligence and often that it reveals
it to be a much bigger and more pressing
topic that
that i want to learn more about
you